all right guys we're starting in
progress with the trump rally today then
i'll be here for biden we will hear from
you in between let's take a listen
support our great police defend our
borders without
borders we don't have a country do we
protect our second amendment protect
religious liberty and ensure
more products are proudly stamped with
those
beautiful words made in the usa
we're starting to do that you remember i
used to say four years ago we're gonna
bring back
the words merry christmas we did right
nothing changed with that big department
stores they're like happy new year i
said no you can say them both but you
can't do one without the other
merry christmas is back you notice that
right
cris we're gonna be there joe biden will
shut down your state's economy
wipe out your factories ship your jobs
to china
to china that's paid them off by the way
china that's paid them off yeah sounds
extra slurry today don't get too much
news but yet enough
you know what's going on they don't like
giving you the news
punish your family with a four trillion
dollar tax hike
eliminate private health care 180
million people have private health care
they want to take it away
and send your state into a catastrophic
do you want to use the word recession or
depression because the word is
depression depression biden has vowed to
eliminate the entire u.s
oil industry no fracking no energy
and gas prices going five six seven
dollars for a gallon
two dollar gasoline good
where are you gonna go with 90 000 cases
a day in the winter no air conditioning
of the summer and no electricity
whatever the hell you wanted right now
you have it made you're so lucky
you are so lucky i'm your president oh
my god
he seems particularly altered today
[Applause]
and your team is doing a good job right
they're doing a good job right they're
doing a good job
and while i'm president america will
proudly remain
energy independent how does that sound
first time
you're energy independent we're the
biggest in the world nobody closed
biden will deliver poverty misery
depression
i will deliver jobs jobs jobs and the
greatest economy
in the history of our country that's
going to be next year anybody seen
stocks lately
yesterday it was announced last quarter
our economy grew at the astonishing
speed
33.1 the largest
now you all know if you lose 31
and gain 33 you're still down 8.23
fact check me do the math guys is it
1952
but more than double think of it it's uh
never been anything like that
for any country not only ours for any
country
in the past five months we've created a
record 11.4 million great right
jobs we have a super v i used to talk
about the v
this is no longer a v this is a super v
this is despite the fact
that the democrat governors have states
shut down right gee does that sound
hey does that sound familiar to you
middle slash family income is up more
than six
thousand dollars under my administration
far greater than the
past administration i mean that was not
up
that was doing very poorly we created
the greatest economy in history
and now we're doing it again make
america great again
again we did it once
it's like extra pathetically dishonest
to them
make america great again again in a very
recent paul
gallup they said 56 of americans said
they were doing better today than they
were
four years ago and we're rounding the
turn on a pandemic and it's 56
and it's the highest number they've ever
recorded so we're doing something right
joe biden spent the last 47 years
outsourcing your jobs
opening your borders and sacrificing
american blood and treasure in
endless foreign wars in countries that
most of you have never even heard of
right i mean think of it and you know at
the debate
did anybody see the debate by any chance
so during the debate he'd say well we're
going to do this i said joe why didn't
you do it
and we're going to do that we're going
to do this and that this and that same
question applies to trump he's promising
a tax cut
a wall they said
that was good that's like that's like a
great football game
no i said but joe i said joe why didn't
you do it
uh well i don't know exactly
and then the last question was a
disaster basically he said
no more oil no more i am keeping an eye
on the biden streams as well because we
don't want to miss that
and i just said we just left a great
place you know that
it was a little cold there you know this
is like warm by comparison more
complaints about the weather it's a
pleasure
ah this is a pleasure how many people at
the rally will end up in the hospital
tonight
i said let's cut this a little bit
shorter
but we have a big crowd you know we had
a big crowd no matter where we go we
have these massive crowds
and i'm going up i'm going up to
minnesota we're going to minnesota
which we have a chance not since 1972
think of it so he's not going to win
minnesota but
they like us up there with the iron
range all the things i've done for them
up there and
helping them when the rioters and
anarchists attacked
we took over and we did agree and our
guests but they should have called us
two weeks earlier in all fairness and
they called
if they called us federal government if
they called us two weeks earlier that
would have been nice you know you would
have had no problem
it took us about what 25 minutes to
solve the problem right
bomb they just marched down but we're
going and the governor just
informed us though that so we have 25
000 people
25 000 people that's a lot you got a lot
here
25 000 people in minnesota these numbers
are always lies like a couple days ago
trump said wow 29 000 people there were
6
000 people it's always a lie we're gonna
go
we're gonna go you're very interested
even if we see 250 people trying to be
honest with you
everybody understands you can't play
those games
that could very well aside from aside
from
omar omar's our secret weapon
ilhan omar that's our secret weapon in
minnesota
this again she doesn't love our country
you know
unlike people that don't love our
country i don't
[Applause]
and the other and you know all about
this because you've had your things the
others we want law and order we got to
have law and order
you look at what's going on in
philadelphia you can't have that
you have to let the police do what they
do i mean they have to do their job
why when i watch that again democrats
it's all democrats when i watch that of
people
are looting stores and you have the
anarchists the rioters but they're
looting stores they're walking out with
dishwashers they're walking out guys has
a dishwasher he couldn't even
pushing it dishwashers
i mean they have television sets and
they're walking and the police are
standing there
and those police don't want to be
standing there they don't want to do
that
they want to be able to do their job but
they're not and you can't have that we
need
law and order as we had
as we had right here as we did a very
good job big on law and order and due
process he would never for example
ask his attorney general to prosecute
someone who hadn't even
been charged with a crime or
investigated for one like joe biden
trump would now he's all about
law and order due process the
constitution
during one of the debates i said joe joe
who endorsed you from law enforcement
and he couldn't answer the question
now that's possibly that happened but
he's got a very bad memory too he can
he was going let me think give me about
20 minutes i'll figure it out
i doubt he has any i doubt he has any i
think we have everybody
we have everybody florida texas
oklahoma chicago
endorses isn't that nice the city
endorsed trump yeah there you go with
all the problems
with all the problems they have for
those they have a great
they have a great group of people from
law enforcement they could stop those
problems i mean you see what's going
on there new york has gone through the
roof new york's finest we have new
york's finest
these are incredible police they could
do the job but they have to be allowed
to do the job
and they endorsed me first time in the
history
of the police force in new york that
they endorsed a presidential candidate
so it was pretty cool
now i'm not exactly familiar with what
happened um
in new york but very often when trump
says the local police department
endorsed him
it's often some sub off group of people
it's not like the police union i don't
know exactly in new york city but very
often he's just lying it'll be like you
know
uh unaffiliated independent law
enforcement
it's sort of like if trumpist police
officers
from a city just have a little club and
the club endorses trump understand that
very often that's the lie manufacturing
jobs
booster groups exactly betrayed american
workers and twisted his knife
into the back of wisconsin workers you
you suffered as much as
anybody biden's also spent half a
century
really a half a century betrayal
essentially black
americans essentially essentially
devastated black families with the
1994 crime bill and he called
black youth super predators a term
that's
a terrible term right super predators
over and over again
trump would never say it and then he
wonders why they're not doing well with
the black vote you know the black vote's
not turning out for him see now we don't
have to go by the fake
record black turnout a 92 percent uh
early
seems to be supporting joe biden those
are the facts not that anybody cares
they remember in 1994 and they remember
him calling everybody a super predator
and that's a term that they don't like
predators
but they're not showing up to vote and
others aren't either
you know uh we're doing great in florida
we're doing great in ohio we're doing
great in
north carolina was fantastic i think
we're doing really good in pennsylvania
sir i don't know about that i think
we're doing good all over the place you
want
another trailer i think we're doing good
all alone
we're doing great here you know i think
they just said to here we're either tied
or one up or tied or one down you know
it's it's
like essentially time i don't know how
the hell i can be tied with this guy
he's shot he's shot he said sir you're
tied in wisconsin you know normally that
means because we have like a hidden
voter
people that don't want to talk about it
they just go out and vote for trump
i never knew should i be complimented by
that
we don't want to talk about it leave us
alone there's more lies
so when you died that's a good thing but
they said sir we're tied
and i said that's interesting and then
the fake washington post
abc right did you see that so we are
todd i was up here two days ago we gave
a great speech that was a cold one
we gave a speech on a racetrack we got a
lot of people and it was freezing but i
got through that i was
there was no way that i leave early
on the great people of wisconsin because
you don't you don't know about that
there is no way anyway this ball so
we're tied let's say we're tied
one up one down we're right boom very
close i think we're going to take it
easily actually i think we're going to
take it
because we're going to have a turnout
probably on tuesday you know our people
like to vote
they like to vote on tuesday not even on
sunday or monday
that's one of the so washington post and
watch the post watch your post abc paul
they come out
17 down donald trump is 17 down in
wisconsin
i said i said wait a minute i just left
the crowd of
25 pounds i don't think biden's up 17.
but i don't think biden's up one i think
he's up probably about six point four
like the other one it's not a second
place crowd
and they did it to me four years ago
with crooked hillary they had me
they had me he's down twelve two weeks
ago i remember
washington post four days now
it's called suppression polls you know
what it does it suppresses the vote you
get depressed you like trump
you know i like the president but let's
uh and then the case four years ago i
like donald trump he's going to do a
good job
we did more than we said we were going
to do we did more than any
administration
has ever done in the first three and a
half years but it's a suppression thing
so they came out 12 down we actually
wrote them legal letters and everything
and then they changed the vote
completely legal letter well we were one
down
but that was the day before the election
two weeks to go 12 down but this one was
17 down
in your state crowd loves it when trump
rattles out numbers
i could also be three up
got so bored they started chanting they
started their own chant
i could be three down i could be four
down i could also be three up a four up
one thing i know i'm not 17 down so so i
called up
the best poster a guy doesn't matter
let's just call him john
his first name is john john can i answer
your question
i just left wisconsin we had a
tremendous crowd it was like a love fest
and then i i wake up true and then i
wake up uh
like two days later and i see a poll
washington post it's all over the place
you know they love it all the fake news
look at all of them back
they're fake
among the most dishonest people in the
world now they have a new thing they
don't report
they don't report on you know
criminality like with the biden crime
family you know they don't want to
report
it's really a disservice to the american
people that it's not 24-hour coverage of
hunter biden flying 3 000 miles
drunk across the country to have three
laptops repaired by a blind guy who
couldn't see hunter but is sure
because of a bo biden sticker that it
really was hunter
and then when hunter didn't pick up the
laptops across the country
instead of trying to get him back to
hunter he read his private emails
copied the hard drive gave it to the fbi
waited seven months and then said you
know what
i don't know where this guy is even
though i'm blind i know it was hunter
because of a sticker
i'm going to go and call rudy giuliani
and then when tucker carlson was going
to report on it
the his homework was eaten by a dog it
was lost the usb drive was lost in the
mail
and ups completed an investigation in 24
hours
but then now that they have the usb
drive back tucker carlson says
it's probably time to move on from
hunter biden that's the story
that the corrupt fake news media won't
talk to you about many polls
and he said the only way they really can
do it they have to make it
so that the people here think you're 17
down and they don't go and vote because
they say it's hopeless
five down four down three down means gee
he has a chance 17 down means
darling let's go to dinner let's have a
wonderful dinner and then watch come
we'll come home and watch the president
lose but we're not going to lose we're
going to win
true true story isn't that some story
that's sad and he knows the people he
said no this is the way they do it
they're very
and then they came with another
statewide 10 down then i can actually
win the state
crowds checked out they don't know
what's going on
in polling but not only paul i mean the
stories
and now there's something that happened
we call it freedom of the press right
this is the opposite then melania said
sir i have corvus
it's now suppression of the press
because now they have stories
and they don't want to have you cannot
get a story out
on biden criminality we have the laptop
from hell
what crime we have the worst things
anyone's ever seen
and they just won't write about it and
that includes big tech
so you know what i'm doing i'm i'm
here's who i'm facing
a corrupt democrat an invisible
accordion is what he says campaigner we
caught him
they spy to the campaign
[Applause]
law and order lock people up with no due
process or even an indictment
see i never do anything to just you know
to to like encourage it because they say
right he led the chant lock him up lock
him up
he led the chain against crooked hillary
all she did was
get rid of three thousand emails when
she got it who did hillary congress
she deleted them she acid washed them
bleached them and then she took a hammer
to her telephones and she beat that
i've gotten rid of a lot of phones i've
never hit him with a hammer
the phones didn't stand a chance my
friends this is a strange
event ron in hillary's defense it was a
mallet well you throw it out
right you throw out your phone you start
all over again
now we got a corrupt bunch of people but
think of it i'm all up here alone
think of this all by himself i have the
democrats
they impeach me for making a phone call
in [ __ ] i make that [ __ ] call to a
man i never met the president the new
president of ukraine
congratulations congratulations perfect
phone call
perfect everybody said it 297 to nothing
in the house the republicans voted right
it's like this perfect phone call
congratulate everyone's telling me
please
call him he just went oh do i have dude
i'm busy right
i said okay i'll call him get the
president nice guy
congratulations by the way if you see
any crime
because we're supposed to have a crime
because it's a lot of corruption
yeah please report it to the attorney
general the united states oh we should
impeach him
i got impeached over a perfect phone
call
but they didn't know we had the call
essentially recorded thank goodness
it was essentially
[Applause]
by very professional people they died
because it had already been way down the
track by the time
the transcribers were killed called up
we said do you mind if we put
your phone call on public record they
said why would that be
it was just a congratulatory call i said
well you'll find out
these are bad people so here's what we
have we have the democrats now we have
big tech now we also what percentage of
people in the crowd do you think have
any idea what he's talking about
and and most of the rhinos i beat
because you know they were all
representing one of the 17 because we
had 18 running
but they were most of whom i get along
with some of them i don't like i could
tell you
15 1.5 nobody but i beat all of these
guys
somewhere in there they end up being
rhinos and bad people
and here we are and we're president
we're going to have
i think we're going to have something
that's even better than what we did four
years ago i really believe that god i
hope so
i hope he's right about that because you
don't have crowds like this
and be on the losing stick you know you
leave here he said gee that doesn't
sound like a second place you can't even
see the end of the crowd
that doesn't look like a second place
finisher
so when you hear about suppression you
have some very nice people up there
about two of them but when you hear
about
when you hear about when you hear this
right
i know every one of them there some of
them are great actually
uh but we're gonna have a big victory
and this election is the most important
election of our lifetime that's true
that's absolutely true
than the last one and i never thought
i'd say it because they have gone so far
radical left and we have to make this
final step and we're going to have
we're going to be normalizing our
country really normalizing our time
feels super normal right now doesn't it
and you know what else normalizes its
success i'll tell you
before the the plague came in from china
they should have never let it happen
but before the plague came in from china
i was getting calls from
people that you would least expect they
said sir we had the best numbers the
best employment the best
everything the stock market all-time
high everything was the best
and they were like let's talk and it was
happening and then we got hit with the
plague
success brings this country together and
we're going to have
we're going to have success trump thinks
that despite never having had a 50
approval rating at any time in his
presidency we were all super united
right right before
the coronavirus some guy gets in that
wants to quadruple your taxes which he
wants to do
he's the only guy i've ever seen we will
raise your taxes all my life i've seen
politicians say we're going to cut your
taxes
he's the only guy ever campaigning on
he's going to increase your taxes
in 2016 wisconsin voted to fire
this corrupt political establishment and
you elected
an outsider as president who is finally
putting america first
if i don't sound like a typical
politician it's because i'm not a
politician if that's okay
is it the same speech every day with the
town names changed
the washington establishment it's
because i was elected to fight for you
and i fight harder for you than any
president
at any time in the history of our
[Applause]
country
talk about uh cult of personality
that's a chance that has never been
heard politically
nobody's ever right even these people
they have there's never been a time we
like because it's a cult
but they've never had that chance so
it's an honor don't keep it going too
long because i'll start to cry
and we can't tell president xi of china
that the president was crying
like qigong president chi
and the fake news would report it
president trump broke down in tears
as they shouted somehow it doesn't work
for us right we can't do that right look
at him he goes no way you can't do it
now we appreciate it it is it's a chant
that nobody's ever heard before
for good reason it started happening
like uh six weeks ago and i said man
that's very unusual
it's a beautiful chance and i appreciate
it very unusual i'm not just running
against sleepy joe biden
i'm running against the left-wing media
the big tech giants and
the washington swamp and it's deep and
vicious
[Music]
and they can't believe what's happening
they can't believe it they would have
taken most people out
almost anybody would have been taken out
and i have been helped a lot
by that man right there named ron
johnson
didn't he have corbett also he's a smart
guy and i knew it
earlier than anybody else i knew it i
had a meeting with ron johnson and we
were going over very complex texts most
people had no idea what we were even
talking about he understood it
so good i mean so he really understood
he understood good
very good understood don't lose him
don't ever listen
you need to show up in record numbers
and deliver a blistering defeat
to these corrupt forces and they are
corrupt as hell
they're trying to take over our country
and we caught them they're coming for
your guns
they're coming for your jobs no they're
not coming for your freedom
think about it your vote will stop them
on november 3rd get out there you got to
vote it's the most important
issue one of the most truly important
issues it's you don't like to even
mention it but it's law and order
and i mentioned that to biden during one
of the debates i said hey joe
say the words law and order can you do
it he wouldn't do it he said law order
and justice actually the left he didn't
want to lose them
he said biden and his party have spent
the entire year inciting violence and
hatred against our police officers
and he refuses to say you got to stop it
you cannot run through portland to
destroy the city i mean it's been going
on
we could stop it in 30 minutes you know
in seattle
i said i don't care we waited and waited
the governor never called we waited
i said you got to go and they took over
a part of the city i mean this is even
to even talk about this who would think
of the seattle
and we were going in and we told them
we're coming in in the morning and you
know what they did that evening they
raised their hand and they left that was
the end of it
and a lot of people are paying a big
price by the way but they raised their
hands and they left
or the statues we signed a law
you knocked down statues they were
knocking down statues all over the
country
you knocked down statues you go to jail
for 10 years
it's an old law oh boy
it's amazing how we haven't seen too
much trouble
with statues there were groups that
formed they wanted to do it they were
they wanted and then they said let's get
staged
10 years it says 10 years in prison old
law that we reenacted
you could never get that passed today
and then how about health care nancy
pelosi and
cry and chuck schumer
crying chuck schumer and nancy would
never pass anything like that
did say uh no you're allowed to rip down
anything you want
you know we have a dc mayor that set up
a commission right
to talk about all of the things cancer
culture let's talk about
they don't like the washington monument
they want it renamed or taken down
they cancel culture conferences we're
not doing
i promise you they don't like the thomas
jefferson memorial
because they don't like it they don't
even know why tell me why
and they don't like even the lincoln
memorial right
they don't like the lincoln so they
wanted recommendations to change the
name or take them down
and i said i think this commission
should be immediately disbanded because
it's not going anywhere but they are i
mean these are
this is a fact take down the washington
monument
these people are stone cold crazy you
have to go out and you have to vote
biden stands with the rioters and
looters and biden wins
no he doesn't before they ask him about
the report he didn't want to come i have
no comment
do you want to take down the washington
monument sir i have no comment on that
uh yeah he has no clue he never had much
of a clue now we know he
i stand with the heroes of law
enforcement these are great people that
we have to
help them
if biden wins the rioters and the
streets
they'll be running your federal
government they'll be running your
government right
random writers will be governors
senators yeah
the biden harris how about harris kamala
it's kamala kamala and you have to say
her name right or she gets very upset
right well you're not saying it right
even though she doesn't say it right you
know
but the biden harris plan would end cash
bail releasing 400
000 dangerous criminals immediately onto
your streets
murderers and rapists this is what's
going on
is crazy when the violet mob it's crazy
a place known as
kenosha did you ever hear of kenosha
because i did remember what i did
if i didn't get if i didn't activate
immediately
kenosha would not be there anymore they
were going to take it down
biden opposed sending in the national
guard and i insisted on it
and i frankly wish the governor asked me
sooner
but at least he asked me but we came in
and that was over in about another 15
minutes right that didn't take long
that didn't take long the theme is trump
doesn't spend more than 10 or 15 minutes
on anything i have kenosha
they knocked down they burned a couple
of buildings down i went i met with the
people and
really good people one was there a
hundred years of photography store was a
hundred years they burned down the store
but
it's going to get rebuilt but we stopped
it that whole
area would have been burned to the
ground so we we came in and
it was so easy too it's easy but you
sometimes have to meet force with force
you can't just stand back sit back and
watch it take place
like they did in minneapolis and then we
went in and it took place very quickly
like usually if it takes like more than
a half an hour
to wipe the whole thing out i say you're
not doing a very good job
biden's running mate the most liberal
senator in america
even urged their supporters to donate to
a fund that bailed out the rioters took
them right out of jail
including a cop killer or an attempted
cop killer
biden wants to lock down your homes he's
ready to lock it down
i mean you guys are already in the
lockdown so you you might not notice it
as much
hey governor you got to open up your
state here you got to open it up
got to open it up
[Applause]
you know it's sad it said you got to go
back you understand you're going to
socially distance you're going to do all
the things you want to do but
i mean we're having these outdoor
rallies it's they say outdoor outdoor
normally would go into an arena i
actually like this stuff better
although sometimes it's snowing and
sleet
i loved that last stop but it was the
rain was formed like sideways it was
going
that stuff that's when you say i love
the indoor arenas but i like these
with a day like this it's so beautiful
it's great is there
any place better to be than a trump
rally in those series
it's great colonoscopy maybe but this
election is a choice between
a trump super boom or a biden depression
that's what it is
and it's also between opening up
and keeping it closed you see what's
happening in europe they're trying it
again they're going to close up
they closed up and they destroyed their
economy our economy is so much better so
much stronger
interestingly unemployment remained
lower in europe than in the united
states and they're only
getting into wave two now we're already
into you know peak three at least
p don't call it a wave call it a spike
anyway number three
or a devastating lockdown that's what
biden wants to do because he has no
choice
uh he doesn't he will not call the shots
he will not call the shots
and everybody knows it thanks to our
historic campaign to slash
red tape and mobilize industry we will
deliver a safe vaccine to the american
people
in literally over the next few weeks
imagine given what's going on
four days before the election
campaigning on cutting red tape i mean
it's it's you would almost wonder if
trump's even sane
this happened before the election so let
me tell you
if biden was in charge of this vaccine
just like the swine flu he was in charge
of
h1n1 right which he can never get right
he can't remember it
it's always messed up sometimes he does
n1h1
i say no but it's the swine flu i said
just go with the swine flu it's easier
right it's the same thing
call it the swine flu it was a
catastrophe
and his own chief of staff said it was
the dumbest run thing they've ever done
and the lethality is much less than what
this was and
is it was and sort of was because
we have therapeutics now that are
incredible in fact here i am i'm here
he got regeneron which is the name of a
company not a medication he gave me a
shot the
regeneron is called eli lilly now have
the antibodies
and i'd like to say it had no impact but
i wasn't feeling good
antibody because of my physical power my
strength
my young age i made the case
i made the case cnn got very angry i
said i'm not concerned
no i i said when i got better i got
better quick
[Applause]
superman cnn got very angry fake news
cnn is
totally fake i said no i beat it because
i'm in perfect physical shape and i'm a
very young person
well our first lady got it it got better
he said sir i have a stuffy nose i
didn't even know we said
the doctor said sir baron has tested
positive i sit for what
and he's very young and very tall he's
seriously tall and he's a good kid but
he's a strong kid but he's a kid and
he is a kid that's true that's true dr
shawn he's great
he's a white house physician and he said
baron tested positive i said for what he
said
for covid you know there's like 30
different names i happen to be sir he's
tested positive for the china plague
it's it's more accurate right
[Applause]
and like you know about 14 minutes later
i said how's baron doing oh he's
recovered fully
i said baron were you feeling bad i
didn't know anything dad
i did what was wrong dad no they you
know they have a very strong by the way
speaking of that get back to school get
back to school okay
back to school right look at ron
saying agrees seniors will be the first
in line to get it and
we will we're making it available free
because it's not your fault that
something that doesn't yet exist is free
to everybody without the vaccine we're
rounding the term but the vaccine makes
it go faster the vaccines are going to
be out very soon
very very soon our vaccine will
eradicate the virus end the pandemic
quickly restore
normal life i just want normal life you
do too
all we want is normal life
[Applause]
i'm looking up to this guy a friend of
mine said you know you're the most
famous man in the world i said
no i'm not no i'm not no he said no
who's more famous than you you are the
most famous
man in the world what a speech what are
you talking about who's more famous i
said
jesus christ oh my god
it's pandering plus narcissism
squared and i don't want to take any
chances
so i looked up and i said and it's not
even close
trump's religious guys remember next
year will be the greatest economic year
in the history of our country
joe biden's plan will delay the vaccine
postponed therapies crashed the economy
and locked down
the entire country he doesn't mind
locking down the country the country
could not stand it
you know we locked it down shortly we
did it we figured it out we protect our
elderly people etc
but he thinks it's fine he loves that
whole deal i'll tell you
all he talks about is covert he gets up
today he's talking
kovit kovetkova kobikova kovakovic
and the truth is we have done an
incredible job with our ventilators and
vaccines and therapy
look at how great we've done all he does
[Applause]
because he's got nothing else he can
talk about because no
administration in the history of our
country has done
what we've done i say it all the times
in the first three and a half years
what we've done with uh tax cuts and
regulation cuts and rebuilding our
military which was
totally depleted and a disaster what
we've done with our military and so many
other things you know them all
nobody's done and they never even
question me you know the fake news with
all the cameras
it's never like where they come oh you
shouldn't have said that nobody's done
until you think of it space force
we could name right we could name so
many different things
under the i mean it's like you know this
is going on but
space force guys drug overdoses
deferred medical care and you'll have
no school no graduations
no weddings no thanksgiving no christmas
no fourth of july
no future other than that he's doing a
fantastic job
biden wants to keep everyone locked up
even young americans who are extremely
low risk like we talked about he wants
to steal
the dreams and the future of our young
people you know
one thing we've learned the you know the
computers are great and the laptops
everything's great and for telehealth
it's been great
where people can see laptops it's really
been i think it's up like 7 000
or something and it's a great thing but
you know for school learning
it's terrible it doesn't work it can't
compare to a class or a campus
they're trying so hard to say oh gee
this is wonderful
it doesn't compare and it's well
documented
you're taking you're taking a large
percentage of a young life
at a play and it's a terrible thing
you're doing to
to young kids and you it's a terrible
thing that's happening with the parents
too
because the kids at school and the
parents are working now the parents
don't know what to do
many of their jobs are gone anyway now
you got to open up your state you got to
do it fast
you got to do it fast
thanks to our relentless efforts only 3
percent of the emergency room visits
nationwide
are related to the virus think of that
three percent because you know what it
is
they only talk about cases understand
how meaningless that is what trump is
saying is there's lots of other reasons
people also go to the emergency room
we test more than any country in the
world by far we have the best tests
these are things that we never even had
six months ago now if i
said let's cut the testing down in half
you'd have half
everyone would say oh the cases are way
down right but you know what it's good
because we know if there's a problem etc
etc we know if there's a hot spot
but that's exactly what it is i mean but
what we do and what
we've done testing other therapies and
if you think of it the fatality rate is
down
85 percent and more now think of that
[Applause]
but they talk about cases because you
know when you hear three percent of the
emergency rooms are devoted you know
it's supposed to be
percent and the hospitals are gonna
close they don't know what's going on
it's
it's been amazing what we've been able
to do
but you don't hear them talking about
death you hear them talking about
because as a percentage
what we've done compared to other
countries is incredible
and now especially with the explosion
that you see taking place over in europe
so we've done a great job and i'll tell
you what our vice president's been
fantastic
and you compare you compare vice
presidents and if you don't mind i'll
take the one we have okay
you talk about a victory at a debate
that was one of the greatest victories
at a debate i've ever seen
what is he talking about it wasn't even
close
excess mortality rate is 42 lower than
europe think of that where cases are now
surging despite very powerful lockdowns
that they've been
they've had very powerful lockdowns i
think they started
three days ago i wanted to just show you
something on a screen
oh no very special people get this we
have a video on our fight against
the china virus and a couple of other
quick things
again we only do this for extremely
important states
and people go ahead so trump now cutting
to a video if you're joining us we are
here
in uh who the hell knows where green bay
wisconsin with donald trump donald trump
scheduled to then after this
rally go to um
rochester minnesota and then we are also
standing by for a joe biden event
scheduled for about 10 minutes ago if
any of you guys are monitoring it i'm
doing my best to check in let me know if
joe biden
actually comes comes to the stage i have
so many other things for you guys and
we'll get back to this rally momentarily
i was going to fill out a map
for my prediction if the election were
today i was going to deal with the
jessie lee peterson
homosexuality thing
i wanted to look at early voting data
already
in texas more people than the total
turnout of 2016 have voted
i wanted to play a little bit of my
interview that i did
with the great jaime camille in spanish
who
is of course from such shows as jane the
virgin and
others did an interview with him for the
spanish show and i've got a little clip
of him doing an argentinian accent
there's just so many different things
that i wanted to do today
and hopefully we will get some time
between
rallies but still waiting for joe biden
phone lines so i'm just going right to
what we did yesterday
we're including website memberships and
twitch subs
but we have a goal of 125. i will do
phones if we get there
so grab a membership at joinpakman.com
so far five people have
eight people have grabbed twitch subs so
it sort of puts us it puts us at 13 i
guess
um and then we will we'll do phones at
some point in between rallies or after
or whatever we've only got a few days
left so i want to make sure to cover as
much of this stuff as we can
um so let's get back to this bizarre
video
and i will keep uh keep an eye on
everything that is happening here
on trade relations with china which
forced american workers
to compete against people making pennies
an hour
has resulted in the loss of 160 000 jobs
the president is
absolutely right when he says that china
has been cheating for 25 years
and that bill clinton didn't do enough
about it george w bush didn't do enough
about it barack obama didn't do enough
about it
rising china is an incredibly positive
development
for not only china but the united states
and the rest of the world
rising china is a positive positive
development
it is in our self-interest that china
continue to prosper
we want to see china rise china is a
great nation
and we should hope for the continued
expansion
china is not our enemy we talk about
china
as our competitor we should be helping
the idea that china is going to eat our
lunch
is bizarre
i mean the fact that this is even
happening is weird maybe i'll just read
a few super chats until the video is
over
um unknown prodigy says david i'll
record the trump video from the rally
and send it to you so you won't miss it
oh that's okay i don't need to see it
the swift falcon says comparing himself
to jesus this is
next level humble bragging um
what else do we have does jesus trump
sound drunk he sounds exhausted
for sure hat mumfree says it's very
concerning how many christians have
fallen for this guy it's a very serious
problem very very concerning i
completely agree with you
completely agree with you um
dan says trump blames biden for division
mental stability and foreign financing
does his criticism of others ever not
reflect his own projection
constantly pair from sweden asking why
trump wears children's gloves
yeah trump's those are really small
gloves but they actually seem
too small for trump's small hands like
trump's hands are small but the gloves
seem even too small
it's kind of weird
that was terrifying what kind of country
we're going to be
four more years of george uh georgia he
uh is going to find ourselves in a
position where if uh
trump gets elected uh we're gonna be uh
we're gonna be in a different world
wow okay you know i like that because i
save a lot of words
you could never duplicate what you see
up there but you see the governors and
then they'll say
although some of them have been actually
very good but we've done a great job
and you see it there and that's what
their real feeling is but when they get
up to a mic
well i don't know if he's done that good
now we've done a great job if you want a
vaccine to kill the virus
a job disappears now we're back on the
prom day freedom to
live your life to the fullest you have
to vote republican it's so important you
have to vote
[Applause]
republican
so we're joined today with some really
great people and
a man that's right at the top of that
list for me is senator ron johnson
horrible person truly vile
telling you you're lucky you have him
he's a fantastic man and he's done an
incredible job but he's got a lot of
courage too
and uh in washington he's respected by
everybody
also congressman glenn grothman
glenn
thank you glenn and mike gallagher mike
thanks mike great job great guys
and somebody that's done a really good
job for us gop chairman
andrew hitt thank you thank you
how are we doing andrew uh because we
don't want
to be doing great sir you'll be out of
here andrew no i think we're doing great
yeah
i think we're doing great i also want to
thank a legendary champion and a green
bay packer personified
hall of famer brett favre for his
endorsement
horrifying you know i got he's a tough
guy he's great
but uh two days ago i saw
that he endorsed me and i just want to
thank him he's a hell of a champion
he's a great champion i look at some of
his records you don't even realize it
but
when you look at passing yards and
touchdowns
right one thing about him tough as hell
and great and really talented so
i want to thank brett favre thank you
very much
decades our politicians spent trillions
of dollars rebuilding foreign nations
now we are rebuilding if it's okay with
you
our nation
i ended the nafta nightmare and replaced
it with a brand new usmca
wisconsin dairy farmers were decimated
under the obama and biden plan
just think about it i only ran because
of them i said that during the debate
too i said joe
never thought of this i ran because of
you people because you did such a bad
job
right he had no response to that
with the usmca or dairy exports to
canada
are expected to surge by more than 100
okay just went into effect and we're not
going to be losing
our companies to mexico and canada we're
not going to have our companies close up
and get rid of everybody
fire everybody and move and do the same
product in mexico
you saw that for it's probably the
number one reason i ran i couldn't stand
watching it
and it's going to be now they're going
to pay a tremendous economic price if
they do that joe biden is a corrupt
politician
oh they took millions of dollars from
the chinese communist party
while vice president biden ship your
jobs to china
how the hell can he negotiate with china
with the money they take
and the news they don't want to cover it
the fake media the lame stream media and
the
and the companies right these wonderful
companies
that obviously don't love our country
it's suppression they don't want to
cover it
if biden wins china wins his son walks
in and takes out one and a half billion
dollars to manage millions of dollars a
year
they walk in where's hunter he wants to
know where's
where's hunter we haven't found him he's
still looking for his laptop from hell
that's where he is
where's my laptop hunter you left it at
a repair shop you never picked it up on
and you know what they go russia did it
russia russia russia
ron it's russia i i know it's russia
i saw adam schiff you know watermelon
head like this
i believe that russia caused this
problem
oh yeah yeah here we go russia russia
russia
we have a great uh great head of dni he
said no it had nothing to do with russia
put out a very strong statement nothing
to do
if it does we let it know we let russia
know
but they said that this is pure
disgusting
evil stuff that goes on and
your tech companies don't want to put it
on you you even even the new york post
which had real courage by the way
right two days ago they are the
courageous ones but they had real
courage
[Applause]
and they took down the new york post
site can you believe it the new york
post the oldest newspaper in the country
fourth largest of the country they took
down the site
now we got to get to the bottom of it
and we will with guys like kim
we will when we win wisconsin wins
when we win america wins right what's
happening under my leadership we achieve
the most secure border in u.s history we
have now built
over 400 miles of wall
yeah they will soon be finished they
don't talk about the wallet it'll be
done any day now
they used that kill me i'd go through it
fight them and would close up and would
do all sorts of things and they would go
after me
once the wall started once they saw we
had all that money lined up to get it
done
and the impact it's had is incredible
it's not completed yet but it will
be very soon and i built it exactly as
border patrol and ice wanted it
sure exactly i said what about concrete
plank
they said sir that's no good have to see
through well
how about this keeping an eye on the
biden rally that's what i like
they said sir we won steel we then won
concrete inside the steel and then we'd
like rebar
i said can you think of a more expensive
way maybe
but we gave it and then we won on top an
anti-climb you know the
thing on top i said why are we doing
that that's very expensive the piece of
steel on top
it's four feet deep can you guys do the
math trump says they're building 10
miles a week
and he's been using the number 400 for
months does that does that check out or
do i need to bring out a protractor
and our record our numbers on the border
are phenomenal the best we've ever had
joe biden has pledged to open borders
mass amnesty
nationwide catch and release you know
what that is that's when you catch a
criminal
murderer rapist you let the criminal go
we argued about this during the debate
he said they all come back for trial no
they don't come back joe
only the ones i said with very low iqs
come back
you have a trial in two and a half years
for murder you have to come back
we released them and i ended it it's all
ended
over that was easy it's not easy doing
this stuff
it looks easy but it's not sanctuary
cities from coast to coast they want to
have sanctuary cities all over the place
and free health care for illegal aliens
which will bankrupt your medicare and
your social security
you will not have social security if you
do that or medicare we all have a big
heart i do i want to take care of
everybody
problem is you have millions of people
pouring in from all over the world if
you do this
as your president i will protect your
borders i will protect your families and
i will always protect
your medicare and your social security
and i've always said it right obviously
bernie sanders crazy bernie one of the
greatest losers of all time this guy
no but i meant that in a nice way
he lost and he went back to the senate
and voted radical left
then he lost again i mean elizabeth
pocahontas
warren all she had to do is get out a
couple of days early
he would have won every one of those
states but she decided not to do that
i don't think she likes bernie okay but
biden will increase refugees this was
agreed
with bernie and the group and aoc plus
three right
highly educated person on the
environment aoc
have you ever taken a class on the
environment i don't think so
has trump increased refugees by
something to say from terror hot spots
so think of that a 700
this was agreed to i don't think bernie
was that bad i think actually bernie
went further left after they made the
deal
and i'm keeping radical islamic
terrorists the hell out of our country
okay if it's okay
look at what's gone on in france over
the last four days
what what's happened in france by the
way i love
people in the middle of this rally
asking me in the chat why they were
timed out like guy i have no idea dude i
would what this this is the entitlement
and presumptiveness i was talking about
yesterday
even more money for combat vehicle
manufacturing in
oshkosh
you know uh marinette's doing a great
job i went to marinette four or five
months ago looked at what they were
doing and we gave the contract to them
which cost me a lot of states but that's
okay
but we gave that to uh i'm only here for
the mercy ban requests okay they were
ready to close a 6 billion
contract and it's going to be extended
they make the most beautiful
ship you have to say it looks like a
super yacht except it's got weapons all
over it you know
i would say paint it gleaming white
and call it a yacht but the weapons sort
of throw you off a little bit you
got more guns and things than that i've
never seen anything like it anyway but
you know all of the positions on policy
trump has stated today they're really
making me think maybe he's got a great
platform
we need it and also it's all made in the
usa it's jobs it's great
best stuff and you know what two and a
half trillion dollars
with the envy of the world with the envy
of russia and china nobody has the
equipment
that we have nobody equipment fighter
jets
f-35s can't see them tanks we have tanks
we have submarines we have everything
what we've done in nuclear we've
upgraded our nuclear we have new nuclear
and all your new nuclear you pray that
we've got new nuclear
that's a big thing but having it and
having it in tippy-top condition
is the best way that we will never ever
have to use it
the last administration where did that
biden event go va policies
resulted in deadly weightless hey guys
in all seriousness
the i was just on this was just a biden
event
the biden event is is gone what
anybody know what the hell happened to
it this is bizarre i'm gonna look around
for it bring bad people that don't love
our vets and take care of our vets
which you could not do under any
circumstances
civil service unions whatever and now
you can do it
jim you're not treating our vets right
get the hell out of here get fired okay
here we go all right
[Applause]
instead of waiting for weeks sometimes
to see a doctor
they go to a private doctor we pay the
bill and it's actually honest it's less
it's probably less expensive
it's probably less expensive but much
more importantly
we take care of our vets you had vets
getting online by the time they saw the
doctor they became terminally ill
they actually had become terminally ill
waiting for so long so now they get out
immediately see a doctor does it even
matter what trump says at this point
91 approval rating for the way we're
running
the va the vets from the vets
we killed the leader of isis al baghdadi
we took out the world's top terrorists
salamania is dead
number one terrorist in the world i
withdrew from the last administration's
disastrous iran
nuclear deal 150 billion dollars
for nothing you know what they gave 150
billion dollars john kerry that's he's
another genius
what a deal that was actually a pretty
smart guy even if you disagree with him
politically
it opened the american embassy in
jerusalem
presidents have been talking about doing
that forever
forever many many presidents they
campaigned on it and then they wouldn't
do it
that's not true i understand why it was
not easy to do
we had tremendous tremendous pressure on
us not to do it
but i did it i did it i just didn't take
anybody's phone call that's all
i also recognized israeli sovereignty
over the golan heights
they've been working on that for 52
years i got it done in two hours
and instead of never ending wars we are
forging peace
all throughout the middle east for no
money and no blood all over the sand no
blood
countries lined up want to make a deal
they all want to come in
after all these years and the other side
and everybody they all said you could
never do it this way
no you could never do it the way they've
wanted to do it
these are just delusional rants i've
done more in 47 months and joe biden has
done in 47 years
a vote for republicans is a vote for the
american dream
and remember the republican party is the
party of
the late great abraham lincoln oh not
this again i gotta remember that
people forget that over the next four
years we will make america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
which has already started
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults or law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
they're
dead they're gone the city will kill you
in the
big tech monopoly and restore
freedom of speech who lost their freedom
of speech we will defend the right to
life
religious liberty and the right to keep
and bear arms
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
and we will ensure peace through
strength we will end
surprise medical billing require price
transparency already signed starts
january 1st will be
bigger than healthcare just got to
reelect them guys prices
even more and they'll be down 50 60
70 percent because i've invoked favored
nations
the drug companies big pharma they call
it does not like me too much
they have more ads and sleepy joe has
against me every time you see one of
those ads remember you're drunk
like they're just plummeting those
prices you're drug plant
and we will always direct mass with
pre-existing conditions right
america will land the first woman on the
moon and the united states will be the
first nation to land an astronaut on
mars
nars we will stop the radical
indoctrination of our students and
restore
patriotic education in our school
[Music]
and we will teach our children to love
our country
honor our history and always respect
our great american flag
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we trust
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america and standing up
for the great people of wisconsin i am
right
for some reason i like you you know why
i like you because we have because they
cheer for every
every stupid thing you say and we kept
waiting for pennsylvania was obvious i
was going to win but the fake news
didn't want to call it
because that would have meant the end
and then out of the blue comes
donald trump has won the state of
wisconsin
along with ron donald trump i was a very
pretty sound and that was it
that was it you know you were the one
you got us over the top you better do it
again
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors
hide your kids hide your wife gotta get
out to vote on november 3rd
or previous to november third just get
out to vote whatever
whichever way you want to do it whatever
way you want to do it you got to get out
to vote this is a very serious
we're doing thank you thank you
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you i
appreciate it
on november 3rd we must finish the job
and drain the rest of the swamp we've
drained a lot the rest
it's fuller than ever from madison to
milwaukee
from jamaica to kenosha and from
lacrosse
to right here in green bay i love green
but i love kenosha too because we did a
great job there we showed them something
right we showed them how to stop them
that was sort of easy but i love kenosha
we inherit the legacy of wisconsin
patriots
who gave their blood sweat and tears for
this beloved nation
we stand on the shoulders of american
heroes
who crossed the oceans settled the
continent
tamed the wilderness laid down the
railroads raised up the great great
skyscrapers
won two world wars defeated fascism and
communism
and made america into the single
greatest nation
in the history of the world and the best
is yet
to come it is the best aside from being
riddled with lies it's also a really
stupid
childhood citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country
we are returning power to you the
american people
[Music]
with your help you're do and
and we are doing that have you noticed a
lot of things
glitch things are changing very fast in
dc
we need this final step this final step
it's going to be something but with your
devotion and your drive we are going to
keep on working
we are going to keep on fighting and we
are going to keep on
winning winning winning
we are one movement one people one
family and one glorious nation under god
and together with the incredible people
of wisconsin
we have made america powerful again our
military is so powerful
we have made america wealthy again look
at what's happening to our country
right we have made america
strong again we're doing it with our
credible law enforcement and everyone
else
we have made america proud again
how much hypothermia are we expecting at
this rally when companies made
america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you thank you
wisconsin
thank you with thank you green bay
get out and vote please get out and vote
most
important election of your lifetime
thank you everybody very much thank you
there it is and then presumably now we
will see donald trump do a little bit of
his dancing couldn't be better timing as
we are just moments from joseph r biden
jr at a different rally
uh democratic senator amy klobuchar and
there is trump
um indistinguishable from parity
putting comedy writers everywhere out of
work
that was a serious political speech uh
for people who joined us part way
through there it is and we thought
and you thought this was a deep fake of
some kind
this is the president of the united
states this is the president of the
united states
donald trump running slightly ahead of
schedule well maybe maybe not
scheduled to depart in the next 14
minutes from green bay
wisconsin uh to rochester minnesota
where he is scheduled to speak in just
about
an hour and 20 minutes uh trump's
scheduled to speak
in an hour and 20 minutes at his third
or maybe even fourth rally of the day
it's just rally after rally after corona
rally
as we've examined these rallies are not
convincing anybody to vote for trump
they're really
preaching to a very stupid crowd willing
to gather in large groups in the middle
of a global hundred year pandemic
there's mark meadows with no mask it
looks like
kaylee mccaternanny over here doing ymca
um i mean these are people who deserve
to never work again
once this is all over and hopefully
um that will be made a reality so
there's donald trump we will check back
in on that we now have amy klobuchar
speaking in her state of minnesota
um people are demanding the phone lines
open
as i said if people want phone lines
open when joe is done
help me by signing up at joinpackman.com
that is our
primary and most steady source of
revenue
grab a membership at joinpacman.com you
can use the coupon code right above my
head
2020 now all one word all lowercase
for 66 off if you can imagine
certainly an immoral discount and even
illegal in some places i also
wanted to fill out my my map
for you guys based on current polling i
had so many different things i wanted to
do
just real quick if you follow me on
instagram
you would already have seen this i do
have a spanish language show
every weekend on estrella
and i interviewed the great actor jaime
camille we recorded this yesterday
of course known uh for such uh
appearances on such programs as jane the
virgin
and many many many others he did
this is kind of funny he did an
argentinian accent for me you will even
if you don't speak
spanish you will hear him in his native
mexican accent
and then just doing me a solid doing a
fake argentinian accent it was a nice
nice moment take a look at this
all right so there it is that full
interview will air you have to check
your local listings it's on the estrella
network 46 cities
uh very very heavily powerful in
california
texas florida and florida it actually
isn't
it's in florida and in florida a lot of
affiliates there
and that will be airing that's sunday
at um where was sunday at 4 pm east
1pm west okay so that is that
uh we just completed a trump whoa now
we've got ads
the trump rally is over uh and now we
are waiting for a biden rally with amy
klobuchar here
very very exciting things going on and i
see people just
continually asking about the phone lines
as i said
the phone lines will open when we get to
uh our goal of members
and twitch subs right now
you can uh sign up at joinpakman.com let
me update the twitch
subs number 1087 so that's actually only
two okay so both count so we're actually
at 31 now
okay we are at 31 and we had some
actually great callers yesterday
i i did a bad thing yesterday actually
i opened the phone lines even though we
didn't reach the goal
and it's a very controversial thing in
the world of
media from the standpoint of honesty
because if we set a goal and then we
don't get it and i open the phone lines
anyway
what what am i really saying you
understand so it's extremely
risky to do that i did it yesterday
because we were so close and i started
feeling guilty
but um i think today we we really will
have to have a powerful showing
and really make it there the website
people i people still joke about when
the website used to crash when like 10
people
went to sign up we have quadrupled the
power of the website and it has not
crashed since
other than the indian ddos attack and
when i i'm not i'm i mean literally we
got ddosed
um by some indian hackers during a
stream
and when i say indian hackers these
could have been american hackers
routing their path through the country
of india that's certainly conceivable
but we had that issue
we resolved it we did a lot of different
things so it's all happening very
excitedly
okay as we wait for joseph r biden jr
let me look at a few
super chats via youtube if you would be
so interested
uh christy says minnesota rallies
requiring that seating for trump rally
be set up for social distancing
should be interesting to see how he
reacts yeah i guess they were planning
on having like 2 500 people
and then local guidelines said you can
have 250
or something like that but we'll keep an
eye on that
sally sumter says when did my drunk
uncle become president what a slur fest
please vote this vile
baby out of office yeah i don't know if
you guys have been seeing the early vote
numbers but as of right now let me
refresh
uh we now have had nearly 86 million
votes cast
30.5 million in person 55 million
mail-in ballots in texas we've already
seen let me switch to percentage of
turnout
100.6 of 2016 turnout
has already happened in texas uh in
hawaii
104 of 2016 turnout has already happened
delaware oh no new jersey 80 i wanted to
see delaware oh delaware's low being
biden's home state in any case
the numbers are truly truly stunning so
we are continuing to watch those numbers
and again it is early we still don't
know really what it means
in terms of the election we have to wait
everybody has to vote um
district level polling in pennsylvania
and florida yeah i know it's not good
for trump but
everybody has to vote we don't we don't
want to we don't want to
just you know suggest it's in the bag
thanks to howard hall
we have now had 32 people sign up at
joinpackman.com
or uh on twitch
um other super chats let me just scroll
i'm just going to get random ones
because so many have come in
mind hack says our emergency rooms are
full green bay
yeah unknown says oh no
we i got that one already hold on do i
think a lame duck trump would continue
to hold rona rage rallies
i don't think so i think the next four
days are the end of trump rallies now
if trump wins and don jr is the nominee
in 2024
we will then have trump rallies again if
you can imagine something more
horrifying
annabelle says good luck for next week
from the united kingdom thank you
annabelle
elliott says david thanks for the
awesome content
thin philosophy says do you think trump
wears small gloves to make his hands
look larger
that there's an idea that's a
possibility that's a possibility
um big thank you to philip mccluskey
who's new member number 33 today at
joinedpakman.com
um also we had wait 1102
so that's 15. another 15 via twitch gets
us to 48.
see the numbers do start adding up they
really do
let's listen a little bit to amy
klobuchar it'll also give me an
opportunity to set our audio level
he will fight for you
this is it minnesota this is it
yes and i want to say one last thing to
everyone
at home watching if you are caught in
the extremes
of our politics right and you're looking
for someone
who's going to stand up for you and you
are tired of the noise
and the nonsense joe knows you
and he will fight for you so let us get
out the vote
these next days let us not let
one political party stop the people of
our state
democrats republicans and independents
from coming together
and electing a man of true grit a man
who loves this nation a man who will get
up every morning
and think of you instead of him and that
is joe biden
thank you minnesota let's go and win
powerful speech from senator amy
klobuchar
wow explosive speech
and there she goes i believe we will
have someone come up and
fully sanit wait hold on
where's joe biden what the heck
i i imagine someone would just come up
and sanitize the
microphone and then we'd hear from joe
biden that was weird
um
okay well we'll wait and see what's
going on big thank you to tracy
steyer new member number 49 at
joinedpakman.com cody camacho
is number 50 and malta gruner
is number 51 very much appreciate that
uh we will open phone lines if we
achieve our goal i don't i don't i don't
really understand what just happened i
don't know why
the signal cut uh what other ones do we
have this is trump
uh oh okay this is the live feed it
looks like they're just doing a mic
check and a little microphone sanitation
for joseph r biden jr and then we should
be hearing from him very very soon
maria says david do you think we should
have left this let the small scandals
pass to not push republicans into a
corner
it's not about letting scandals pass
it's that after six hours there's a new
scandal
uh so it's it's uh it's more complex
than that
more complex than that um eric says hi
david just voted in person glendale
arizona let's go biden
enrique says may the flying spaghetti
monster bless america
ramen yes very very much
uh what else do we have here
kirsty likes watching me laugh
hysterically at trump's word vomit
during the rallies yeah
it's sort of funny but it's also really
really scary
because um it is the president
after all and the fact that he can't
even be remotely coherent for
a minute is not a good sign for the
country
not a good sign for the country uh we
are waiting for joe biden in saint paul
minnesota as we speak donald trump is on
route from green bay wisconsin to
rochester minnesota and
as you can see we appear to be just
moments
moments from joe biden's speech
and i expect better weather than last
night last night's speech cut
short for joe biden by torrential rain
and uh looks like a bright and sunny day
in saint paul minnesota as we await for
joe
uh wait joe biden the crowd is in cars
it is a drive-in rally
drive-in socially distanced safe
rally as they say these days
um trump continuing to ridicule joe
biden for taking the virus seriously of
course
you know when you see this you realize
it's pretty bad it's pretty bad and then
you say oh wait a second maybe it does
make sense to take this seriously
uh i wanted to play the jesse lee peters
i just don't know if we have time i'm
worried if i get away from this biden
we'll start speaking
i'll just stay here i also wanted to
play for you
this clip from the john ossoff david
perdue debate
it i believe it's i believe it's a
murder i believe when i watched it i
witnessed a murder
it's like nothing i have seen before i
want to play that for you but we'll get
to all of those things in a little bit
thanks to allison ramsey who's new
member number 52 today
and joelle nordstrom who is new member
number 53
then when we add in our twitch
subscribers there are three more
which puts us at 56. do you guys like
doing a higher goal but including twitch
subs in it what what do you think
do people on twitch like it and do
people on youtube like it do the or do
the youtube people
oh hold on a second um
we have some anti-semitism in the
youtube chat
that is an insta-ban and gun
um man a lot of band hammers are being
dropped it's it's
it's really incredible really incredible
people seem to want yeah they prefer the
inclusion of twitch i think that that's
right
i don't know who this is but there have
been so many speakers before joe biden
it's
like let's bring biden out at this point
you know let's listen see what's going
on
with you today my name is jessica
intramil
and i am a minnesotan with a
pre-existing condition
we have all heard all year how this is
the most
consequential election okay so we're
still waiting for joe biden we're not i
mean it's like with five rallies a day
we can't do every speaker at every rally
um so we're going to uh we're going to
stand by
i want to hear from you guys johnny
minogue says via super chat even with
your awesome commentary
i can't stomach the trumpy horror rally
shows for very long anymore
voting in person tuesday yes on question
2.
teresa says i'm never going to like
hearing ymca again
yabbit says my david pakman membership
with a misspelled pacman
has really helped get my dad and my
family through this thank you
no yabbits thank you thank you
um jackson janney asks if i will be
streaming tuesday
i will i will be streaming tuesday
um and i i'm getting very conflicting
opinions from people about is the is my
tuesday stream going to be crazy or is
the tuesday stream going to be a dud
because
there's just so many people who are
going to be streaming i don't know i'm
just going to do it you know it's like
i'll just it's a pandemic i would just
otherwise be home watching tv
so i will stream i did go and look at
our numbers from 2016.
we peaked listen to this we peaked
at 15 or 1600 live viewers total
across all platforms in the 2016
election night stream 1500 or 1600.
um i think we will do better than that
by by
a factor of many but i don't i don't i
have no expectations for how
the tuesday stream will go what i care
about is what are the results
what are what are the results going to
be on tuesday but yeah i look forward to
seeing
at least some of you here at least some
of you here big
thank you to hector reyes who is new
member number
57 today and chris druda
who is new member number 58 adding in
an additional six twitch subscribers
puts us at 64.
we may actually get those phone lines
open today
uh very very interesting uh okay
other super chats coming in johnny oh no
we already got johnny and then chip
chip patty chuck chippity chuck
retracted
issued a powerful retraction message
serge says from canada
we really hope biden wins it's not just
you guys
a lot of people here hoping for a biden
win as well
let's see what messages are coming in
via twitch subs
slingblade says thanks for all you do i
appreciate that
and an unconscionable amount of
subscriptions donated by spudnik19
spudnik19 thanks to today's donations
has entered the top three sub-donors of
all time
i'm inconsolable uh david chadman
at number two and spudnik okay how about
this i will do the jessie lee peterson
thing
but let me know in the chat if biden
shows up
monitor the bite can you guys agree to
do that monitor the biden stream
so that if biden starts speaking i can
get back over and then i'll go over to
the jesse lee peterson stuff is that
fair
nobody will do it okay that's too bad
dear god
okay no people are doing it okay so
here's the deal with the jesse lee
peterson stuff
jessie lee peterson is a known homophobe
who has been saying for a long time
homosexuality is bad it's evil all this
different stuff
um jessie lee peterson was caught caught
and i don't you i hate to use the term
cot because
there's nothing wrong with being gay the
problem is when you have a life
of of attacking people for being gay and
you might be gay yourself
he i guess accidentally liked gay porn
on his twitter and then he it came up
during his show and his explanation is
inconceivable and it expresses no
understanding of how twitter works that
this is jesse's explanation take a look
at this
okay so you know like i'm not licensed
expert with social media at all yeah
whenever i
use it i'm like just really one two
three those simple things
right but over the years i've had
friends of mine who told me who would
tell me
social media is mean they put nasty
things on there on your youtube channel
and so i had a friend tell me once i
won't mention his name but
yeah he's a real popular social media
person we're at a conference once
and he was telling me that and he was
like
tick and i had never seen him be king
oh i was uh i just started out for the
most part
not just started out but he was saying
that these radical homos okay we're
gonna get back over to biden who is
speaking here we go
and forced to think not only about
facing the battle
but about how they can afford the
treatment
while insurance companies come
[Music]
and in at the most vulnerable moments
for you and your family members i
remember when my son beau
was lying in the hospital after he came
home from
iraq after a year he had stage four
glioblastoma they told him not whether
he
was gonna live but just how long would
he live
as he lay there fighting for his life
fighting to hang on i thought to myself
what would it be like
if it is suffering my insurance company
here's the insurance company's able to
come in and say you've run out of
coverage
time's up you're on your own
well folks it's a question no one should
have to face in america
that's why i fought so hard and why
obamacare was such a big thing
it's unconscionable
it's uncomfortable with donald trump
from the day he got elected till right
now he's fighting in court
to rip that peace of mind away from tens
of millions of americans
but we're not going to let him do it
we're never going back to those days
and you're going to vote we're going to
win for you
jessica and your family and i promise
you
i will protect your family as if it were
my own
i want to thank all of all the speakers
you heard earlier
your governor tim is great who's leading
minnesota
with decency and integrity and one of
the outstanding
members of congress benjamin mccullum
let's send her back
to the house of representatives we need
her badly
and your incredible junior senator tina
smith who i got to speak a little bit
back here
she's got to go back and look
let's win back the minnesota state
senate
while we're at it
one of the nation's finest leaders and a
dear friend i've been honored to stand
alongside
and fight together for the soul of this
nation for a long time
senator a.b global car amy i love you
thank you
thank you yesterday in florida
i had a chance to spend a little more
time with another minnesota icon
carl anthony towns you gotta hurt him
where he can play man you all know him
as the heart and soul of the
timberwolves
but he's also the a son who like many
other americans
lost his mom to coven 19
a couple months ago for all those sons
and daughters
those parents siblings husbands and
wives
facing empty chairs and dining room
tables
have empty holes in their hearts all
those who reach over at night
implicit just by instinct to say
goodnight
to their husband or wife they deserve so
much better
these guys are not very polite but
they're like trump
[Applause]
[Music]
but look they're gonna be okay we're
gonna take care of them as well
we need to come together we need to
fight for all these folks
we have four days left to get it done
four days
and millions of americans are already
voting middlesboro will vote
by tuesday and i believe when you use
your power the power to vote
will change the course of this country
in the course of history
right here in minnesota with all of you
in the final days
keep that sense of empowerment keep an
important empowerment with you that
sense of optimism
what we can overcome now look there's a
reason they don't want to hear me
because they know the president doesn't
say anything
so they're not used to not hearing
anything
but i know it's hard folks i know it's
hard more than
228 i believe it is now thousand
americans have died because of coba 19.
more than that nearly 2 500 here
in minnesota gone we had 9 million new
cases nationwide
millions of americans are out of work on
the edge
they can't see any light they don't know
where it's going
and donald trump he's simply given up
over the weekend white house counsel
chief of staff
he said the following we're not going to
control the pandemic
at the debate last week donald trump
turned to me and said we're rounding the
corner
it's going away we're learning to live
with it
but as i told him no he's asking us to
learn
to die with it we're not going to
and did you hear what he said today
what he said today on the trail he said
that our doctors
our doctors are first responders
over a thousand lost their lives are
putting their lives in the
this this isn't great i'm not gonna lie
in total with the
now with the constant honking in the
background the rhythmic honking
because they get more money the
president of the united states
that may even be a car alarm not a honk
i don't even know what that is
of making up covades so they make more
money
doctors and nurses go to work every day
to save lives
they do their jobs donald trump just
started to stop
attacking them and do his job
[Applause]
folks this the same man
who weeks ago when he was told we're
losing a thousand lives a day
you remember what he said he said it is
what it is
that's thoughtful well it is what it is
because
he is who he is
donald trump has waved the white flag
and surrendered to this virus
but the american people don't give up
they don't cower
neither will i remember when he told
when he did that interview he told bob
woodward
that he knew about the virus how deadly
it was the end of january
but he didn't tell anybody he didn't
even tell those folks
he didn't tell anybody and woodward
asked him why
and on tape he said because he didn't
want to panic the american people
the american people don't panic donald
trump
panics
[Music]
and unlike donald trump we will not
surrender to this virus
look president trump is spreading
division and discord
he thinks that he can divide us
we won't notice his failures thanks for
the raid book smarts on twitch
that's why he shamelessly equates somali
refugees
folks seeking a better life in america
contributing to this state in our
country
with terrorists as he did last night
we need a president who'll bring us
together
not pull us apart i'll deal with this
pandemic responsibly
bringing the country together around
testing tracing masking
it's estimated by the leading doctors in
this country
that if we just wore a mask for the next
few months this guy's killing it by the
way 100
000 lives of over 200 000 lives they
expect to lose
dr fauci call
for a mass mandate last week
this isn't a political statement like
those ugly folks over there
beeping the horns this is a patriotic
duty for god's sake
in his own words as i said
the president knew back in january how
extremely dangerous and communicable
this disease was and i told you he went
on and he made that tape
he said it with the disease was easily
able to spread
but he did nothing he did nothing at all
look folks
american people are people are tough
and instead of talking and politicizing
the vaccine
he should be planning for a safe
equitable and free distribution of a
vaccine
when it comes next year
[Music]
this guy refused to provide schools and
small businesses
the resources and the national standards
open safely
what a mess the house of representatives
already passed the money
to allow schools to open safely
businesses open
safely to make sure people are paid
ladies and gentlemen will bring
republicans and democrats together to
deliver economic relief
for working families schools and
businesses
[Music]
this is really insane guys like trump
did an hour
where it's just free word association
about things that have no connection to
reality
biden is sort of like yelling and
there's horns just
persistently going off rhythmically it's
just a mess it's a mess
there's no doubt about who we have to
vote for but what a mess
but we can build back and we can build
back better
with an economy that rewards work not
wealth
we can do it without raising taxes on
the middle class and working families
i promise you you have my word if you
make less than four
hundred thousand dollars a year you
won't pay a penny more in taxes
but i tell you what for the first time
in a long time
the wealthiest and biggest corporations
are going to start paying their fair
share
91 out of the fortune 500 companies paid
zero in taxes last year
why why should a firefighter an educator
it sounds like rhythmic horn guy has
been moved further away like i can still
hear it but it's quieter
pay higher tax rates than the super
wealthy
why should you pay more taxes than
donald trump pays
[Music]
[Applause]
he's exploited every loophole and tax
code
he's run a shell game to avoid paying
taxes if you notice
i've released 22 years of my tax returns
he's not released
one single year what's he hiding
where's the corruption according to
trump
the reason why i only paid 750
is because he's smart well what does
that
make the rest of us to pay our fair
share mr president
we're going to deliver tax relief for
working families in the middle class
help you buy your first home pay for
health care premiums
or child care or care for your aging
parents
or be able to actually actually pay for
school
trump got a supreme court justice first
time it's ever happened and
while elections already started for one
reason
he's determined to do what he's been
trying to do for four years
destroy the affordable care act if they
get their way
100 million americans will lose
protections for pre-existing conditions
complications with covert 19 will be the
next brexit hey so
where how are people in both youtube and
twitch chat and how are you aware that
the got that the guy honking is a
trumpist is there like a twitter account
or how do we know
for the same healthcare as a man just
because they're a woman
donald trump thinks healthcare is a
privilege i think it's your right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and if we all get out and vote we'll not
only restore obamacare we'll strengthen
it and build on it
so you can keep your private insurance
if that's what you like oh you oh biden
called him
yeah i thought people were saying the
actual protesters said something
lower your premiums and deductibles
out-of-pocket spending
reduced restrictions yeah also who would
we're going to keep the protections for
people with pre-existing conditions
and will protect social security
medicare
meanwhile the social security actuary
said
that if donald trump donald trump said
elect me again and i'm gonna change
social security
the actuary said if the changes he puts
in place
occur screwed to be bankrupt
in 23 2023
so go home and tell your parents your
grandparents this is like sort of not
that great i'm kind of worried about
protect social security
the energy medicaid
but folks nothing's worse that this
president has done
than the way he spoke about those who
served in uniform
he called them losers and suckers
my son beau
gave up the attorney general's seat in
the united state of delaware
to volunteer to go to iraq for a year
he won the bronze star the conspicuous
service medal
he wasn't a loser or sucker he was a
patriot
so many of you as well no wonder the six
generals who work directly for the trump
administration have left
and they say he does not deserve to be
the commander-in-chief of the united
states
right that's never happened to any
president before
and that's why special operations
commander stanley
general stanley mcchrystal navy seal
commander admiral mcraven
along with 24 stars endorsed me
saying they support me to be the next
commander-in-chief because they trust me
and that's why the military times
reported that more troops will vote for
biden than trump
that's why we have to support the
military they're the backbone of the
country
so let them vote and let's vote for them
and while donald trump fails to condemn
white supremacy
we can deliver on racial justice the
season of protest has broken out across
the nation
because the life and dignity of george
floyd sensely killed seven miles from
here and so many others that mattered
and a lot of people are getting banned
today what is within
protesting it's violence clear and
simple and will not be tolerated
but these protests are a cry for justice
the names of george florida taylor jacob
blake
will not still be forgotten not by me
not by us not by this country
because true justice is also economic
justice
access to schooling housing access to
capital
good paying jobs and financial stability
giving families of color a real shot to
own a home
start a small business send a child to
college debt-free so they can build
wealth
and pass down opportunity through the
generations like the rest of us have
we have to vote to ensure the full
promise of this country for everyone
and finally we have to vote to meet the
challenge of the climate crisis
the west is on fire losing more forests
than the total land of connecticut and
rhode island
combined the midwest is flooding
here in minnesota extreme weather occurs
incurs big costs
for your infrastructure increased
flooding in the mississippi
watershed is shut down port facilities
here and in saint paul
donald trump thinks it's all a hoax he's
a
he sure is a stable genius
he says the wind power causes cancer
i say creates jobs minnesota jobs
we combine we can combat climate change
with american ingenuity and
manufacturing building more resilient
nation
creating millions of new high-paying
jobs
we can change the path ron nothing's
beyond our capacity
so honk your heart if you want america
to lead again
[ __ ] your horn if you want americans to
trust each other again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] your heart if you want to have
civility again
this is the worst year isn't it and hark
you're hard
if you want america to be united again
[Music]
[Applause]
we cannot afford four more years of
donald trump
in 2008 and 12 you've placed your trust
in me and barack obama and each day
we're in office we work
for you and the entire community i'll do
it again in 2020.
my campaign is a broad coalition of
democrats
republicans independents democrat
republican office holders i'm running as
a proud democrat
but i will govern as an american
president
i'll work as hard for those who don't
support me as those who do
because that's the job of a president
it's the duty of care for everyone
and you too have a sacred duty the duty
to vote
it matters minnesota matters
so in the final days stay empowered stay
optimistic stay united
make a plan to vote help get out the
vote
as amy said go to iowa really chaotic
events
yeah yesterday the federal affairs court
forced a last-minute change in the rules
absentee ballots had to receive by
tuesday
so if you want your voice to be heard
drop off your ballot
don't put in the mail or vote safely in
person
any day up through election day but
you've got to get it done
and make sure everyone you know votes as
well
so they'll not be able to stop us
despite
trump's efforts recent press article
points out
that quote never before in modern
presidential politics
i'm quoting now never before in modern
presidential politics
has a candidate been so reliant on
wide-scale efforts
to repress the votes as trump end of
quote
we will not be silenced over 85 million
of
people have already voted 85 million
they've had enough look
i'll never forget the words president
kennedy said when he promised to send us
to the moon
he said we're doing it because we in
america we
refuse to postpone
i refuse to postpone the work america
must do
there's nothing beyond our capacity
there's no limit to america including
guys like that
the only thing that can tear america
apart is america itself
and that's exactly what donald trump has
been doing from the beginning
divide america treating americans
against one another based on race
now the audio is cutting out that's
wrong that's not who we are
knows who donald trump is let's keep
showing them who we are
we choose hope over fear
we choose unity over division
science over fiction and yes we choose
truth over lies
so it's time to stand up take back our
democracy
we can do this we're so much better than
this
we can be who we are at our best the
united
states of america god bless you all
and may god protect our troops thank you
thank you thank you
thank you thanks appreciate it
wow
[Music]
um is anybody else exhausted
what is going on now joe bi oh his mask
okay putting on his mask good
uh there goes joe biden my god
completely chaotic event
and uh i mean he's fine you know he's
saying all things that are good but just
the the energy
the honking the screaming i don't know
that if i were biden i would be doing
the screaming i think he's screaming in
order to
sort of seem higher energy this is an
insane situation in which
uh we find ourselves and uh obviously
we must remove donald trump and elect
joe biden it's not about biden having
the wrong policies he has a lot of the
right policies but this
this is just crazy crazy crazy crazy
and we now have the next trump rally
is only 42 minutes from now so things
just getting wild i i am exhausted from
that
but um i want to hear from some of you
uh i i may take some phone calls as i
said we have a goal of 125 we're at 77.
twitch memberships twitch subs count and
really
we keep the highest share of every
contribution
when you sign up at joinpackman.com so
head on over to my website
grab a membership in all seriousness if
you like the work that
we do if you appreciate the clips
the streams all of these different
things it's really really cheap we're
talking two bucks a month okay join
pacman.com
use the coupon code above my head 2020
now
or sign up on twitch and if we get to
125 we will open up these phone lines
um pseudo spike said via twitch
i'm supposed to be in my born-again
pro-trump step-brother's wedding in four
weeks in jersey there will be very few
masks should i still go
listen you have to figure out what level
of risk is right for you
i assume in a month in new jersey it
obviously has to be indoors
i would not go but it's up to you you
know you have to figure out
what uh what what makes sense for you
robbery says website member and
twitch sub i appreciate that and then
laurie
says 11 month subscription glad to be
part of your team glad to have you
okay so let me get back to the jesse lee
peterson thing okay so we're in the
middle of jesse lee explaining
how someone liked gay porn on his
twitter account which of course
is not believable at all it's just all
uh
um completely unbelievable especially
putting nasty stuff on his uh
on his computer on his social media
thing
and he didn't he wanted to know why why
were they doing that
why he would find himself clicking on it
not realizing that
uh how he was seeing it or something
like that
but he was 10. and but so apparently
according to my social media people
they're doing it to me too
these nasty homosexuals are putting
their nasty gross sex
stuff on onto your social media and what
jesse doesn't understand
is if you look at someone's likes
nobody can put anything on there it's
like if your account got hacked
okay say your account got hacked but
it's not like your facebook wall
where anybody can just put gay porn i
mean it's just
you know if jesse lee peterson is gay
i would like him to just say you know
what all of my homophobia
for all these years was disgusting
and i did it because i was scared to
just say who i was
like you know you know what i'm saying
instead of doing this routine
set it up to look like you're just
looking at something
else or that make comments and if you
don't know what you're doing
right apparently you will find yourself
looking at it i often wonder
how come whenever there is evil right
that you always can find the radical
nasty homosexuals involved in it
so he's still even i guess now he's
implying that radical homosexuals
put gay porn on his twitter but it's
like it was just a like
he liked it you it's not it's not a
facebook wall
to be involved in hell and so if
be careful with you if you don't know
sir and i'm from the old school so
i don't know who did this but right it
could be anybody on social media you
better hire someone to do it for
jesse all right so explain to the people
what happened uh
chris oh this i haven't seen i guess he
asked someone else to explain
chris is my social media guy uh there
was so that they won't click on this
stuff or who about you know
a lot of times they don't even know what
this should be good yeah there was uh
like pornography in uh on twitter
like twitter allows pornography on their
website yeah twitter allows the porn
i know i i'd counsel so many men and
women who are addicted to that stuff
because they
just see it time other people even young
people
yeah why don't they ban that stuff on
social media yeah it seems to be uh
younger and younger people are accessing
this yeah right it's not 72 year old
jessie lee who liked it it was like a
kid
yeah and so there was um there was
pornography in your
in your likes on twitter and so
i i was unaware of it and then uh
somebody sent it
and they uh you know people started
spamming all your calls so actually
it's plausible that jesse lee doesn't
even use
his twitter and it was actually this guy
who was looking at the gay porn like
that's also
i have to say i haven't seen this before
that's also a possibility
it's uh sending pictures of that posting
it all over your posts on
uh on twitter and you know
that type of stuff accusing you of being
a homosexual how can people
void that look at that is there
something that they can do to avoid it
i guess jesse thinks they need
counseling i don't know well
i mean you can preemptively
block stuff from your social medias i
think you can maybe turn on a filter
that's what jesse was doing he was going
to all of the gay porn twitters which by
the way
i've never even accidentally come across
porn on twitter
but i guess the way to do it jesse would
be you you go to each gay porn
account and after checking out you block
it
that doesn't allow you to see um
certain content yeah but i mean you can
block people on on twitter i guess he
would need a list of people to block
on well why are you doing this why do
the
nasty dirty homosexuals in the
in the [ __ ] who are into that stuff why
do they
impose that stuff on you because they
know it's raw they know it's dirty they
know it's evil
right what is the purpose because i was
talking to
a young person in counseling and live so
and they were saying that they became
addicted to porn
because it's on their phone and it just
pops up when they don't in 10.2 you know
how can people avoid this stuff if uh
social media owners
don't block it like they do
conservatives
yeah you need some warning or something
yeah i mean pornography this guy has no
idea what to say
at large i mean it's becoming more more
and more mainstream which is un
unfortunate it's just you know society
at large is becoming
ever more demoral imagine like trying to
get off the topic of the fact that gay
porn was in your likes and
it they make it a moral question about
society it's like it's about you
it's one of these two guys you
understand as the day goes on
yeah and there's an attempt to really
normally
understand that right as these two guys
are talking
one of these two people i guess because
this is the social media guy and it's
jesse's account one of these two people
was looking at gay porn on twitter and
liked it
okay and they've now been going on for
what five minutes
uh and making it a societal issue as
like overtly sexual things you know
television films
you know those are very sexualized the
unfortunate thing that when these young
people run them on this stuff on their
phones and all that
and they get into it it destroys them
right it really destroys them
and i'm wondering maybe parents
shouldn't allow
[Music]
their children to have phones and all
that and let them buy whenever right but
in this case it's too adult so it's not
an issue
of children maybe they won't be so
traumatized
i uh they should be doing that
uh unfortunately i mean it really is oh
my pr guys there reported to twitter
yeah you can report things to twitter
but these guys they don't seem to
understand
if you're going to report something you
would have to argue you got hacked
someone went in someone accessed your
account they got your password
and then they went in and all they did
was like one gay porn tweet
that's report what to twitter or like
really
like attacking you it's pure evil folks
but fret not right so my pr guy said
you can report it to twitter and also
delete it
delete it no you also can't delete it
it's not your post you liked a post you
could unlike the post and then it
wouldn't show
okay anyway we got to get off of this
because this is this is just
completely toxic i can't even understand
what what it is that's going on
where is the upcoming uh where was that
upcoming trump event
joe biden trump holds a rally biden
holds a rally oh it's this one okay let
me start closing out some of these
others
uh really really wacky it's just it's
total and complete cringe it's really
insane
okay um mike roddick says how does brian
tyler cohen get
kamala harris for an interview while you
interview the likes of jessie lee
peterson okay
so a couple different things it's not a
really fair comparison as far as biden
people
you know we did interview like biden
campaign
co-chairs like the la mayor eric
garcetti
uh congressman ruben gallegos but what
you have to understand is i'm not even a
democrat and i'm certainly not an
insider i don't have any contacts at the
democratic party
brian tyler cohen actually is a dnc
uh you know sort of a friend of the dnc
so
so that's why and it has nothing to do
with with subscribers
pookie says remember when people used to
think pacman was gay
i was featured in a documentary about
bullied gay teens who had committed
suicide
um i was actually featured in it it was
and i was not a teenager i was alive and
i wasn't gay
it was weird to be included big thank
you to
eliza veda taranova whose new member
number 78 today
andrew laidlaw is number 79
andrew eid is 80.
trudy roth is number 81 and
gabrielle fox is new member number 82.
we're also counting twitch subs and we
have
an additional five of those which gets
us to
87 87 i made a pledge
to open the phones if we get to 125
total today
but i am i i really am not gonna do it
unless we get there because otherwise
you know it starts to get a little
starts to get a little crazy
um the price of
dreams says david i just did a photo
shoot where most of the shots were taken
naked am i destroying younglings how can
i become evil
you were naked or the people you were
filming were that sounds weird
joel says would joe bite on expanding
the court if it was fair like justice
is chosen by groups of five to ten
senators is it a good strategy to the
loot six to three
i have a clip about expanding the court
everything i have to say about it is in
that clip
and then skate alex as jamie harris and
lindsey graham debate is at 7 pm
okay check this out i believe that this
is video of a murder
check this out this is john ossoff the
democratic candidate for
georgia senate in a debate against
senator david perdue
i have never seen anything like this
okay take a look at this perhaps
senator perdue would have been able to
respond properly to the covid19 pandemic
if you hadn't been fending off multiple
federal investigations for insider
trading
it's not just that you're a crook
senator
it's that you're attacking the health
of the people that you represent you did
say covid 19 was no deadlier than the
flu
wow you did say there would be no
significant uptick in cases
all the while you were looking after
your own assets in your own portfolio
and you did vote four times to end
protections for pre-existing conditions
times and the legislation that you tout
the protect act
it includes loopholes that specifically
allow
insurance companies to deny policies
to georgians with pre-existing
conditions can you look down
the camera and tell the people of this
state
why you voted four times right to allow
insurance companies
to deny us health coverage because we
may suffer from diabetes
or heart disease or asthma or have
cancer in remission
why senator it is i i have never seen
anything that brutal it is really uh
just unbelievable i mean it's it's it's
shocking what happened and
case in point um david perdue
canceled the next debate and said we've
debated enough
uh we are we are not doing any more
debates and and actually bailed on it
um altogether which is really really
just
completely bonkers um
okay uh all right i think so we we've
got
we're things are dropping off from the
standpoint of audience so what we're
going to do is
this stream is going to end here i'm
going to get a couple things done
and reset and i may be back
for the next trump rally scheduled for a
half hour from now really probably
starting in more like an
hour and i am going to be raiding
over on twitch who should we raid i
don't even know
um maybe we will raid of the people i'm
following
nobody else is really oh let's raid um
oh you know who we're going to raid
alexandra botez
actually because she um
you know she's been a friend of the show
so we're going to do that over
on twitch we are going to be raiding
there
do i need to hit start raid right away
or do how do we do this i don't know or
do i just do it
do i just click it now or do i have to
wait for people to get involved
i don't even know i guess i'm going to
hit start raid and
um oh i see here we go okay so then i do
start raid and then we do raid now
okay guys so thanks to everybody and we
are going to be back
strongly powerfully extremely soon
uh thank you so much
it's always bad why would you like is
always bad
why do you why would you want me to lie
to you like if i'm playing badly i would
want to know the truth
you always